okay hello everyone welcome to my fourth
live stream for today uh a design review
of language functionality for version
13.1
related to discrete computation
and this looks exciting oh my gosh
this looks exciting and not so short
okay
let's start off with
graphics is not discrete computation but
that's okay
um
all right
drop shadow effect hey by the way
whoever's not on mute and make
background noise maybe you could
um
so this is a 2d effect is that correct
yeah
so this was requested initially for text
basically for
geography
labeling
but it's a general effect and it's the
beginning of a new effect series of
functions so basically image effects
with shaders can be turned into symbolic
primitives
okay
do we like the effect word at the end of
it
i think it's a good
i mean they need to be a family give me
some examples of other ones
a blur
blur effect yeah
why isn't it just blur
because blur is already a function
charles can you please mute
um
uh
you know so we have filling functions we
have shaders
and sort of directives with filling for
2d with shaders in 3d this would be
effect
um
so if i just say
something like this
and if you do that in graphics
and
if that's not
you know it's the directives it comes
before the circle
kind of like thickness
there's a specification to how
that's not right
i know it's not right
okay not obvious that it shouldn't be
like this
see i think this is more what people
would expect
i mean you're saying it will be style
i i find this very weird that it's that
it's called effect in this case
if it's working that way it affects
everything that follows it
i i don't we should be promoting style
it's a much better
more encapsulated more sure sure but it
works interchangeably
no i i understand that but i'm i'm not
i'm asking
okay let's continue for a second what
other kinds of things so i mean clearly
i could say you know
give me an example of one that's a
shader based one to put in here
uh we do have you have only we've only
filling once and those are for solid so
for this okay so let's say disc and
let's say um
uh cross hatched is that what we call it
patch feeling
hatch filling
so you cannot combine both at the same
time so it's a
one at a time
that's not what i expect with style
right with style i expect to be able to
combine things
that's the point what you're signing up
for is
a style like effect right
right
so why can't you combine them i mean
because one's running in a gpu and the
other one isn't and
what's currently this first year this
first technology limit which maybe at
some point we you know
can be resolved
but also it's more a directive
because of the way we actually think
about using it
right okay so hold on let me i'm just
still just trying to figure out where to
store this
where should i store this because i
don't have a place that is a combination
of these three things
if you store it in graphs i can find it
okay
just create a directory called g
okay so sorry charles i i'm sorry now
i'm listening
so i mean if i take if i take the drop
shadow away from here
okay we're hatched
okay
now so you're saying there's a
technology limit which it prevents these
from working at the same time
right yes
okay
but
are you arguing something else about
them or just that it's a current
technology limit
no i was just also kind of explaining
why we went with the height because um
actually we you know we check both way
if you know it can actually be wrapped
around the primitive we should make it
behave like a primitive right
and in general primitive means you
change the geometry which in this case
is not changing the geometry
but also
having it has a primitive i mean
a wrapper around the primitive will make
it hard to actually use in
plot function or any other you know
general
graphic
generator or function of generated
graphics which usually just most of the
time text styles
i see so you're saying
what we don't support right now and this
is a bigger question
is graphics of framed of disk for
example
right spluff
by the way
um
oh gosh this is something for the code
assistance folk
we should do better than just pink box
on this
am i making sense
kristin i think that's for you to mark
mark this time and then
feed that to the code assistance folk
yes you have an idea on how to do better
or what you would prefer to see well i
think first of all just the very
statement that don't use for you know
framed because we know about this
particular confusion so we might as well
message this particular confusion
for example i don't think it'd be bad
inside graphics to turn that framed red
because we know it's wrong
right
in fact
what if you had what if you had cosine
there
instead of framed
well i i think we might want to turn
that red too
i mean in other words i i think that
once you're inside graphics
you know these things which are built in
symbol system system symbols you know if
it was x well who knows it could be set
to something but cosine is not going to
be set to anything
but i hadn't
sure but it has to be if it knows
see this is the point that that
okay
let's not have that meeting here but i
think there's a good idea which which
the concept because actually this is
something that would have would have
helped me many times just one of these
things i haven't thought of this is
actually should also go to user
assistance because it may be more their
thing
to even when you're typing in graphics
if there's something in there that's
poisonous you might as well
color it
i'm making sense
because this could never work
right you might as well color that red
are making sense
i think so
i mean i'm not sure what school it is
but i don't know i don't believe but
what you could do
is to have a positive statement of
what's allowed
basically a grammar
yeah and it deviates from that grabber
you could color it yeah yeah i
understand that i mean that's
implementation detail but i'm i'm saying
well if it's unimplementable it's not
going to be i i i understand but from a
user experience point of view i think
changing that color is the right thing
to do and i should have thought of it
earlier okay but let's come back to what
you're talking about here
all right so
just tell me some more effects other
effects scroll down down
first of all charles you can enumerate a
bunch of effects but anything in the
same effect could more or less be one of
these
i think i mean we have some in a couple
of examples you know into documentation
there
this whole question about what auto
rasterizes versus what doesn't i mean i
could imagine somebody just having a
piece of text
and they want to put a drop shadow on it
because just like i can say
you know i mean i'm having a hard time
distinguishing between
you know this
why doesn't that do what i think it does
what the heck
oh i know why that doesn't do it that's
a style style
okay so so then i'm going to ask the
question here
i think i would expect to be able to do
drop shadow effect here
what the heck is that
oh it's just just the well the type
setting it have parameter default
parameters okay it's fine
but okay i'm gonna claim that this
should work because i think by the time
i'm doing this you know in your way of
doing it where this is just a naked
primitive that's one thing but often you
use style
i don't see any good reason why this
shouldn't work
i you know have to make it work on day
one et cetera et cetera et cetera et
cetera et cetera but i don't see why
that shouldn't work
that that effect used to work on like
the original you know mac in 1984 or
something
remember that
yeah sure it's easy i mean
user is here and probably john will have
to discuss more about it how to you know
propagate it you know to the whole
front-end side
so
not just be limited to graphics so
that's the thing
yeah we need to investigate the system
joining our support
uh not all the system joining layer
support uh
of this kind of font styling
okay so
yeah
but we can investigate
okay
all right
but so in terms of
okay
why do you want to call it effect rather
than styling
or drop shadowing or something
again
you know we've got hatch filling
could you tell me some more of the
effects you imagine will be supporting
charles
there is for example blur already
several of the image effect outline
okay so so let's take a look at what
they actually are
okay
so are we going to have a generalized
one that that supports any image effect
or not or is this specific to things
that some drawing hardware can do
well at this time we're just going with
what people commonly use in graphics
than what people do generally in you
know with image processing and all the
modifications right
and it's not that extensive like in in
this case especially that you want you
know you want the performance that you
want it to actually run on the gpu and
such okay okay okay but i mean which of
these we realistically
you know like like stippling
is something that we effectively have
with what is it called
that's not hatch filling but once one of
the other
what is it called
um
[Music]
staple shading
also called staple shedding
oh yeah okay
so that is stippling right so that's
stipple shading
which is what we've called okay so which
of these realistically
i forget this one this torn frame effect
i mean that effect by the way i would
like to propose that we promote that
somehow to
the ordinary frame thing because i find
that really useful
this torn effect thing i i agree with
you i think we've actually talked about
that previously could you make that a
note this time code and note
whoever makes that
the um
yeah i think this general idea of an
excerpt
uh you know
i know whether we want to say torn
because there might be different effects
there but uh a way of accepting
from a um
uh
you know a piece of an expression or
something like that is is useful okay in
any case so let's be realistic what
other things from here are you going to
have
i think comic is probably toon shading
in the same family right
which we have
okay fine
but i mean i i'm looking for
i mean
i don't even think that that
okay
you're defining so i'm going to climb so
so like for example
you know a hand-drawn effect
you know would be something that i think
we would
get some use of and
i agree
yeah
that's what we wanted for a long time
like hand-drawn curves and things like
that
see i'm kind of thinking that drop
shadowing like hatch filling
is better than drop shadow effect
style drop shadowing
what do you think
i think it helps to have the word effect
there and i think they're all so
different and hatch filling you could
think of as an effect but we're calling
it filling which it is
does that make sense
how do we make drop shadow experimental
now and then see if what how it evolves
okay could we make it drop shadowing
sure
and
what do you think about drop shadow
versus drop shadowing
i think drop shadowing is better because
i think it's more the ing
is more like it's an adjective
see what i'm saying
and drop shadow is the noun yes it's the
thing that dropped
exactly okay this is this is sort of the
adjectival
it's not hatch fill it's hatch filling i
i i
i admit it's a fuzzy
area but um
um
and so in 3d we'll we'll probably have a
shadowing to make shadow in 3d
well shadowing altogether in 3d
wonderful if we have a thing called
shadowing it's a lovely thing to do have
i mean i i assume there will also be
potentially a drop shadowing in 3d where
it drops to the the baseline you know to
where it drops as opposed to shadowing
where we have to define the lights and
so on right
am i making sense
is that what you're talking about you're
talking about ray trace shadows is that
correct
yes the shadow yes it's actual shadow in
3d yes
um
well
uh
what else but that will require lots of
other parameters
shadowing i mean this drop shadowing is
just a little cutesy effect
whereas shadowing
shadow making is a is you know there's a
there's a whole science of shadow making
you know it's how you make sun dials
see what i'm saying i mean it's more
complicated isn't it
this is just a little effect which is
the cutesy thing yes but right so can
can we get some clarity on yours
proposing that we have something which
represents which says this object should
cast a shadow is that correct
um yes okay but that's not the same as
drop shadowing which is just a cutesy
effect yep yes right okay so in 3d is
there a cutesy effect that is like drop
shadowing
for example dropping down to the
baseline just like we have you know
filling in 3d
right
which
annoyingly is an option right the the um
right as opposed to hatch filling which
is enough you know which is one of these
adjectives
uh making sense do you understand what
i'm saying is drop shadowing a thing
that's going to work in 3d
um not a mother of usually just a 2d
effect okay but but let's be clear okay
so look look in this case right
so let's look at what this does
oh for god's sake
yeah the hash filling are just to the
directive
okay we've got to do a bit better on
this messaging here because this is
really crazy
an improperly formatted directive with
head hatch filling was encountered come
on that's incredibly user hostile
surely we can do better
and for example that message should
absolutely be changed to say
hatchfiddling is not supported in
graphics 3d
or some such other thing
right as opposed to an improperly
formatted directive does anybody think
that's a good thing brett do you think
that's a good thing
it's a very awkwardly worded thing
it's awful and we should fix it
okay
so is that for you or is that for the
front end team that's the front end team
okay well fine so kristen you need to
take that to them yes
okay
so but now this effect if i said what do
i call it stipple what what's what's one
of the effects that does work here
let's do tune shading
okay
now
okay so shading is the 3d thing
i mean it's annoying you know sandra is
commenting on our live stream drop
shadow back in the day with the mac it
was just like bold and underlined
right so the fact that we're making it a
heavyweight thing like this is tricky
right
especially because
i i mean guys
so did drop shadow just work for text
than in the mac
i mean i've never used the old mac
yes it was 1980s yeah it was just text
it did not work for it no it did not
work to my knowledge it did not work for
graphics primitives okay
it was just an effect like boulder
underline i think
and people used it too much okay
producing stupid looking stuff
um
but look roger if your demographic
doesn't know about it probably you know
it's like at some moment some things
that we might think might confuse people
we don't care about because there's
nobody around
that
i mean and it was i do remember when
people got their first laser printer and
they used 12 fonts on one page i do
remember that
okay
so i think it should be drop shadowing
and i guess you could make it a a
like this let's take a look at its
actual
oh my gosh
really
uses an absolute offset in what in
points or what
yes in point print of points
well i mean that's probably right in the
sense that it's not anything else okay i
think this is okay let's call it drop
shadowing and make it um
okay but you shouldn't just say polygons
specifying the graphics objects
are to be rendered with an additional
blurred offset image or something
because it isn't just polygons it's also
text which is very different
it is isn't it yes yes you'll fix that
and and you should show this example
without a box around it just show the
actual text
do you understand what i'm saying yep
yes
to make it clear that's what what's
going on
well so so the way you should describe
this is
it's as if the light is a certain
distance away or something right isn't
it i mean this is this is the angle and
this is the well i don't know maybe you
don't need to say it that way by the way
charles it would be really good if you
could get an audio setup where you don't
have a lot of weird background clickery
um
the anyway just i'm just complaining
about that
um
doesn't mean you have to go on mute just
means yeah
um
okay
so the drop shadow effect i see it's
always usually it is a shadow which is
assumed to be sun colored so to speak or
inverse of the sun color as opposed to
inheriting the color of the object
itself
yes yes
okay all right let's move on
seems good to me okay
flat shading
oh my gosh mussier mr
guerrero and okay so this is perface
shading per vertex shading per pixel
shading
is another way to say it
really i thought phong shading was was
because of these you know this exponent
or something i mean we've had no so the
big thing with fong
is that
you get the normal so everything is a
poly polygonal surface ultimately right
so you get the normals in each corner
you interpolate the normals and then you
compute the shading equation at each
pixel
that's what fung does
guro
you run the shading equation at each
for each corner
and then you interpolate the colors
okay so let me tell you something i mean
having known about this a bit for 40
years
right
that wasn't what i thought the story was
now maybe i'm just clueless
but as i recall there's an exponent in
phong shading it's there's in both
so but you can see how that doesn't
really come out very nicely guro
yeah i mean my understanding and it's
even in like the version
how you looked in the version
one or version two
mathematical book let me look i have one
on my shelf here let me just pull it out
and let me look it up in the index and
see what we said
what i said i guess
um
well because we have specular reflection
for for
lighting model page 457
i should be pulling it up online but i'm
not because i don't know
we do have it online
we just boringly read
oh boy
okay we should look at this this is not
quite as obvious as you think it is
me let me pull this up i think i can
find it online
uh
let's see
hey please could we stop
clicking noise in the background please
please please
okay where is the freaking book oh
what
where's the actual book
oh there
okay
that's kind of pathetic huh
wow copyright 1991 okay
okay
here we go surface color what's the
relationship between what you're talking
about here in the surface color
primitive
guys
hold on i was just going to get a book
okay well uh i'm not sure i remember
what is what was the original surface
color definitions
but what i want to point out that there
is i don't if if we still have that
function
and we do
you can't just ignore it
you can't just say
okay all right so this is okay i see
it's been superseded by specularity and
glow
what and i think the exponential you're
actually pointing out is coming from the
form of effectiveness model so there is
difference between the phone shading and
default fitness model
ah okay so let's take a look
here
fong lighting model which i'm calling it
here right
so that one yes the specular have an
exponential
okay so you're saying that the shading
scheme is different from the lighting
model
what they happen to be invented by the
same person or at least a person but the
same name
yes
oh obviously not sure about it but i see
that you know there's that distinction
between the shading and then the model
okay so i would claim given this
confusion that we would what is this
background noise what's going on i don't
understand
um
okay
i don't think we should use these named
i think if we want people to actually
understand what these are as opposed to
just you know
calling jokes by numbers
you know i think we should come up with
other names here you mean like bessel
function
yeah that's calling jokes by numbers
yes that's an example of that right
because that's a thing where okay that
particular one
is common enough in those fields like
like for example we didn't call
differential route
you know something some obscure thing
after campaign fourier or something
no there is also the point that actually
you know myself i was not keen to
actually introduce this shading because
they say they're more academic than
anything else our you know system shader
is you know is much far better than this
these models right but if i remember it
was during actually the last review that
user actually requested that they want
this basic standard model you learn it's
called flat shading google shading font
shading
i think flat shading is useful
flat training you want for debugging and
for just generally seeing what's going
on
i mean do we think this is for
educational purposes yeah you think this
is i think that i think that you're in
the end are not going to use guru
shading i think you're going to use flat
and phone if you're going to specify it
okay if we were to name these things by
what they are what i think they really
should like if you look in the standard
book in this real-time rendering by
academics
this model the shading model is
explained on page 71
lighting and shading
and it's exactly what i described
you know in terms of
no no no look i was confused because
whoever fong is or was
you know obviously did two things right
so i was confused so my confusion has
been resolved
okay but but my question here is
if we were going to name these so flat
shading
these are the names used too
in those textbooks
flat guro and phone
um
okay but
my question is this
if we wanted i'm just for the exercise
for a second if you wanted to describe
this
as you know pixel level shading
versus
interpolated shading versus flat shading
is that what you would call it or
something like that
um yes and you see then in the c also we
have it you know face pair
vertex yeah charles wrote it there very
nicely called this per face shading
or per
vertex shading or per pixel shading i
think those are those are kind of good
yes
where did you show that where did you
see the very first line after the gray
box or the
brown box
okay
so that will be face level shading
well what would flat shading be
face level shading
vertex level shading and pixel that's
obscure
i don't know
i mean i admit that that's kind of
obscure
and you know there's precedence that you
know i mean tone shading goes shading
you know staple shading also falling
down all right
okay i've named things like this you're
saying yes
all right
um
what does that mean attenuation factor
for the diffused light i thought this
was flat shading why is it why is there
any attenuation at all
oh well it's we just added a you know a
scale parameter to
you know in some cases you just want to
control the intensity of the light so we
attenuate it
but it's not required in principle it
doesn't have any i mean is that the
albedo or is that something different
what are you talking about here is this
the albedo is this how bright the object
is
white pretty much okay but then isn't
that controlled by another parameter
i mean we just decided to add some
parameters i mean we don't really need a
parameter here for flat shading we just
decided to add a parameter so it make it
easy for attenuate okay so can i
understand the following question
how do you determine the albedo of an
object in our shading models
did you understand the question
what
what's the answer how do i determine the
albedo of an object what is it specified
by
so the better by default is the base
color of the object so it's
coming from your user specification and
then we use a better to determine the
final color based on the light so the
albedo is basically the thing has an
intrinsic color that's multiplied into
the light is that correct yes pretty
much yes in
our standard shading model for the light
okay so here you'll decide
deciding to multiply by a gray level
basically
because if i put here
you know pink for example
that doesn't
you say a factor here so that's
basically a gray level correct
um i i think so at least for
notification yes
but i don't think this is right i mean
in other words that if you want the
thing to act as a certain color
then
it was not really it was just to kind of
modify the the the definition you know
the intensity of the diffuse lights all
the ambient light
right
well okay but but if that's if you're
giving that control i don't understand
why you don't need that for albedo as
well
why we don't have an albedo
wrapper just like we have a glow wrapper
that can give you the
you know this level of control because
right now the color of the object it's
an orange object
right it is
the alberto doesn't change right
but the light
the sim i mean it's coming all built
from the phone shading where you have a
full control on the ambient specular and
diffused light so those parameter
control essentially the intensity of
those light so we attenuate those light
well the alberto doesn't change which is
the base color of the object right so we
apply then the
you know
the shading model
right and it's from that you know where
we combine the ability to color and all
that i know but you could perfectly well
take it a different way you could say
this object has an albedo
that is
uh
you know that is different for diffuse
ambient specular
um light
right you could you could say that
just as instead of putting that into the
shading
maybe i'm confused but i mean it
no no it's i mean i understand what you
mean i mean we can actually modify that
which is the base color here we just
focus on the light than actually the
alberto yes but it's the same thing i
mean in the end there's going to be a
pixel that's a certain color and that's
a product of those different sources
right
white
but there is a complex dependency
because our light themselves have color
right so there is there is all that
but what's the difference if the albedo
is a colored albedo you're just
multiplying that value by the light
value are you not
um no not that straightforward i mean
the the whole shading model is more
complicated
and i mean that's why we wrote the whole
tutorial in for the material shading
where we actually emulate that fully
okay so you're saying that an albedo so
you know to my mind okay i'm gonna make
a picture of the moon okay with an
albedo of 0.1 or whatever the heck it
has
right
and
if i change
the albedo of the moon
the moon should get dimmer in my picture
right and that's that's a parameter that
you are saying
is somewhat independent of the hackery
of these lighting or these shading
models
there's a there's a just like glow is
almost a physically defined thing
so i'm saying i claim albedo is also a
sort of physically defined thing yes no
i agree and yeah that's that's actually
correct yes
and that's so all those data
modification is actually what is
implemented in the material shading
with more details that's why we have the
base color you can actually modify the
base color
you can modify the gloss specularity of
your object right of your actual
material
so where you have that full detail
control with a specific
reflection model
sorry i i spaced out for just a second i
apologize could you could you say that
again
i say if you actually look in material
shading you're introducing your version
is where actually you have all that
control where the base color is actually
the alberto and then it
you have a full control okay okay okay
okay
so i see so one of these parameters is
albedo
help why is this spinning
what the heck is this doing
um somebody should check this
okay it might just be this version or
something
this is lovely by the way
where is albedo
base color is the best color
might be nice to call it albedo although
albedo is usually a multiplier it's
usually a
you know an uncolored multiplier
see what i'm saying the albedo of the
moon is it's like i'm sure we've got it
in both alpha i mean if i say
yeah i was more or less right in my
remembering that was 0.1 there we go
right so
i thought albedo was just
how much it reflects
it is it's like the coefficient of
restitution you know like like how much
it bounces back right yeah that's the
answer
right so what i'm saying is if if we
have a material right there should be a
coefficient here which is like the
albedo and you're saying it's the base
color but that's not the same thing
well is it is
ugly but what i mean is that white if
you know all all those parameters are
based on the reflectance model
right in material actually we built a
referentialized model where you have a
base color and below that you see you
have metallic coefficient of net
coefficient
where then you can control that so there
is equivalence so it depends you know
what model you are using
fine but why aren't you providing
you're saying that if i provided an
albedo and then i provided a base color
which one wins
is that the issue you're raising
um
no
what i'm pointing out is more like
there is a reference model people are
using right same as our material shading
heavy you know easy yeah you know
physical base or fitness model right and
then you know from those different you
can actually do a mapping
or you have to parametrize it
appropriately
so here there are better we have the
base color which is followed by metallic
coefficient of the coefficient which
allows you to actually do that whole
food parametrization and have the effect
you want
okay so what you're basically saying is
there's a change of coordinates that you
could do
from base color and metallic coefficient
and so on into albedo and something else
if you wanted to
is that correct
but the so there are different
coordinate systems for representing
this
this thing and we're just not using that
coordinate system just like we don't use
but this looks like a more refined model
yes i agree
so which is fine although it'd be useful
in the documentation to to indicate the
correspondence but that's a minor thing
okay but let's come back to what we're
talking about here
so are you saying that we could use
material properties material shading as
well as garage shading or does that not
make any one or the other i'm pretty
sure
because that doesn't make sense to me
because they're all gonna lead to sort
of shader equation and you have to run
one equation or another
okay
so
okay so then what we what you're saying
is you're feeding in as arguments here
these parameters which are
the
it's not a freaking attenuation factor
is it
it's a multiplication isn't it
what what is it is it a is it a pure
albedo-like
well it is a motivation factor i mean
the best way we wanted to say it is the
way you can alternate the light
right in our definition and we try to
make it between 0 and 1.
it is what you're not doing over here
that is what i could do is i could say
you know my glazed what whatever it is
you know i've got a red light
and my knot here
is reflecting 0.2 you know 20 percent of
the light
right but instead what you're doing is
you're saying the knot is green
and therefore when it is illuminated in
red light it will do such and such
correct
right
okay which is a complicated mess
because
uh you know
in fact i'm i'm totally confused by this
i'm sorry i'm i'm completely confused
i'm reminded of a
i mean you we are discussing different
performance models the pbr the material
shooting is completely different than
the flat shading
i understand that i want to just
understand this this lighting thing okay
and what i've been saying that
multiplication versus base color
i'm i'm reminded a stupid personal story
i was like probably eight years old or
something and i managed to was at some
place where it was on some
uh
boat dock which had sodium light and i
managed to cut myself and i was like
covered in black stuff or so i thought
which i figured was oil
but turns out in sodium light you can't
tell the difference between blood and
oil
because it's monochromatic light
so
hence my question of if you have a green
knot and you illuminate it in red light
what does it look like
what does that even mean there's nothing
nothing i mean if you if you
if you dot multiply red and green
and zero
nothing comes out
well but okay but so a base color i'm
trying to understand guys if there's a
base color that's green
and it's a red light
what comes out nothing
black oh you open you do graphic 3d and
then you do red
not data or
sphere and then you put the lighting to
be right and you see the results
see the result what is the result
yeah you can you can run that experiment
but you have to kind of control
everything because we send multi-colored
lights to it and things like that okay
so graphics 3d of sphere
let's say and i want that sphere to be
styled
according to
um material shading no just make it
green didn't you want to do the
experiment green no i want to do the
green experiment okay i
okay and then i say lighting
what do i do here
well you don't want white because it has
everything in it
i i know how do i do this because don't
we have this new way of doing light
sources where i can put it the light
sources right here yes
okay so let's say light sources
no ambient light and
okay so let's say
ambient what is it called
ambient light
but not actually maybe in this case we
wanted directional light maybe just to
see it clearly
okay let's say ambient light and then
let's say red
yeah
what oh yeah you need to get rid of the
light sources it's still shining um you
know you still have a bunch of stuff
shining on it
lighting down
okay
just like my blood so yes yes
the
okay
so i understand that okay so then
and i am so freaking confused i mean
let's say i do this let's say i say
blend
uh let's say pink and green
yeah you'll get something
the pure green component yeah that's
that dot product is gonna just pick out
all the greens in that ambient light so
so in other words the color model
is a three-dimensional vector
yeah
okay
i understand
um
so that's what base color means
is multiply by that base color the three
dimensional vector in that base color
correct
that reflects yeah i think that
certainly does in the standard shading
model and but this
this okay so now here for some reason
this is a pure scalar multiplier
right rather than a color multiplier no
no it uses color too and this is a
different diff you use a different
shade reflectance model
okay so no no no but steven if the
material has a color
the light has a color
it will still
combine the two
that's not what the shading you know
affects it just
um
you know it's going to do it one per per
face
you know so it's going to be a constant
color across the face i understand that
in the case of flat shading but i'm
asking the question
in this case and i can obviously do the
experiment here right i can say here
uh
what i want to do i want to say
flat shading
let me do it for a dodecahedron
okay would it be better if i were using
directional lights would that be more
helpful yeah
what can i do here tell me what i should
do
well here let me okay okay hold on so
this is
okay so now this
i believe will be equivalent to
saying flat shading of 0.5
what the heck
what's going on here there's no light at
all there's nothing coming in
so we said lighting none but you don't
you don't light it
shading just say how you combine the
lights and the material it does i see i
see i see i see so so what i really want
to do sorry i i
i got this wrong what i want to do there
is i want to say
flat shading and then i want to say
ambient light
that gray level but then then i should
get 0.25
not the same thing why am i not why am i
getting the same wait a minute what's
happening here i should be getting
i'm totally confused i should be getting
okay hold on this is that
okay fine
now flat shading
here
if i say gray level
let's say point no if i say in flat
trading grade level point one this
should be very dark
oh for goodness sake
what's going on here
is this a really implement i mean
i don't understand either actually no
the flat shading there is for diffused
light the d is on the diffuse light
there's no diffuse light here there's
ambient light
yeah well you should have said that yes
okay but i think that's super confusing
okay no no it does say that in the text
i know it says so put one one no not in
the list so one
command okay so let's try moving that up
to point five
oh okay okay okay all right so it did
the right thing but we were all pretty
confused we were pretty confused
and um
now
this
we actually don't care about that's not
gonna make any difference
but we're wrong
okay explain well the ambient light is
3.5
i see so what we're doing then is
combining
okay this flat trading is a pure
multiplier
it is not the case the flat shading is
uh you know red is is if i put in a
blend color there that will not work is
that correct
but is the that parameter is just a
pyramid flyer that's pretty much it but
it's pure what it's a multiplier
multiplied so it's the albedo quantity
that i've been talking about before
just a multiplier yes it's just a
multiplier
as opposed to a convolver like this base
color is
yes yes
and is that because of the
implementation of some gpu shader or is
that because we thought this was a
better parametrization or why is that um
no it's just that i mean if you start by
looking at the phone shading right
so in the whole perfectass model you
take into account the ambient light
diffuse light
and specular light
we just kind of carry the same
parametrization pretty much on the
global shading and then the flat shading
and since the flat shading doesn't
really the specular light doesn't really
affect the flat shading that's why you
know it's just two arguments instead of
three arguments
that's very useful it gives you a way to
weight the three components of the
shading equation basically
that's not bad it's not bad no
but now how have we done the other
parameters here so for example the
specularity okay
specularity is
taken to have that specularity and
that's the exponent
i kind of feel like these will be more
natural on a list but maybe i'm wrong
you know i would kind of suspect that
the the plane
single value would would affect all of
the lights
see what i'm saying
yes
and then that you put in a list to get
more detailed control over diffuse
versus ambient
does that make sense
yes
you can do that
okay let's have a look at the um uh did
i bring up
um
phong shading
uh that's exactly the parameters you see
there
the dsa concept where this is just da i
guess that's all right
i guess it's all right
right so fong shading open open close
would be equivalent to functioning of
one
which would be equivalent to font
shading of list one one one
right yes
and the only case that i think is tricky
is functioning of list a single list one
which i think should be one zero zero
see what i'm saying
yes
okay looking good
all right you convinced me
anything else to look at what's this
what lighting uses
accent
okay
what does that mean what is the accent
uses a directional light and basically
produces colors on the surface but is it
a white light yeah yep it's just that we
you know by default our our default
light is a color light
so you should say directional white
light there okay
stephen we didn't think we thought the
probability was zero that we would get
through this today so i think that corey
has already scheduled another one for us
asap okay all right well let's just let
me just get a sense of what's here
and then um
oh yeah we talked about these before
right this reconstruction mesh thing and
so on
yes
is this a bucky play
yes
it's amusing
why is it called jd sick
well in in this case actually dude you
know is the way people call it the
judicial in the
polite because
i know but it's it's named after gdc
dome but why is a geodesic dome
called that in terms of the usual
meaning of geodesic the shortest path on
a sphere and things yeah i was thinking
about that too i i did i don't think
that they've ever implemented it using
athletic geodesics i think they're
always straight
yeah that's what i think too which is in
fact exactly not gd6 right
quite true
maybe old bucky didn't but maybe
compared to an um a style roof it's very
geodesic
this is a very planar roof yes okay fair
enough that's probably what it means
it's probably judy's sick in the sense
that it is
more
geo geos
geoid like than um
oh boy okay
wikipedia claims that geodesic dome
comes from geodesic poly
that there reminds me of this recipe to
demand each other as as ingredients
tahini requires to well i forget what it
is but they require each other
i assume that you've looked at all the
bucky things in the function repository
right
right i mean it was from your last
meeting you requested those so that's
why you added it yeah it's coming from
there okay great
as opposed to this just being in graph
data
it's probably useful enough to be to be
its own thing
i'm gonna have to run
okay all right well we should okay to be
continued then guys yep
um play asap
yes thanks okay
see ya